bienvenidos a en 5 minutos donde
intentamos explicar de manera sencilla
asuntos complicados todos hemos oído
hablar de bitcoin o cripto monedas que
son estas cripto divisas que pretenden
revolucionar el futuro a qué se debe su
auge y cuáles son sus riesgos tanto
ambientales como financieros como su
nombre lo indica son divisas que sirven
para comprar cosas también son digitales
como cuando pagamos por internet con
nuestra tarjeta de débito o de crédito
pero a diferencia de éstas el sistema de
pagos se hace de usuario a usuario sin
intermediarios bancarios o
gubernamentales otra de sus
particularidades es que están
encriptadas pero como es eso de que
nadie las regula y que están encriptadas
las cripto monedas funcionan bajo un
mecanismo que se llama block change o
cadena de bloques un libro digital
compartido donde se registran todas las
transacciones públicamente pongamos como
ejemplo la más famosa de estas cripto
monedas el bitcoin digamos que pagamos
un automóvil con un bitcoin de manera
digital como lo haríamos con nuestra
tarjeta de crédito
hasta aquí todo es normal lo que cambia
con las cripto monedas es que no hay un
banco o entidad que verifique la
transacción y por ende nadie centraliza
ni regula sus movimientos según ideó en
2008 una persona o entidad que se hizo
llamar satoshi nakamoto la script o
monedas funcionan en mediante una red de
usuarios que pueden acceder a todas las
transacciones de bitcoins que se hacen
los usuarios mantienen sus fondos en una
billetera digital y cuando se hace una
compra por ejemplo la del auto esta no
pasa por un banco central sino que se
envía a todos los usuarios de la
plataforma de tal manera que cualquiera
la pueda corroborar eso es lo que se
llama una red peer to peer o ret entre
iguales pero como asegurarse de que la
transacción es verídica si nadie la
regula cada transacción se emite con un
código o algoritmo que debe ser
desencriptados a esta labor se dedican
personas o entidades con servidores muy
potentes son los famosos mineros de
bitcoin los mineros forman bloques de
varias transferencias desencriptados y
los comparten con el resto de usuarios
estos bloques se van uniendo a otros y
así se forma la cadena de bloques o
blocks y es un sistema muy seguro porque
para que alguien pueda cambiar los datos
de una transacción verificada deberá
alterar un sinfín de transacciones y
códigos ahora de dónde salen los
bitcoins a diferencia de otras monedas
que son empresas y emitidas por los
bancos los bitcoins nacen de la minería
los mineros cobran por su trabajo de
desencriptar y verificar mensajes y se
les paga 6,25 bitcoins por cada bloque a
partir de la minería se han creado todos
los bitcoins del mundo el tope
establecido son 21 millones y de estos
ya se han minado el 80 por ciento ahora
si a qué se debe el auge de las cripto
monedas el hecho de que no haya
intermediarios ni cobros extras atrajo a
muchos usuarios cada vez hay más bienes
y servicios que se pueden pagar como los
autos apartamentos o incluso una pizza y
los expertos indican que estate será
cada vez mayor e incluso plataformas
como paypal ya las aceptar pero la
llegada de la script o divisas se ha
basado también en una gran especulación
y en promesas de que se convertirán en
las monedas del futuro esto ha hecho que
por ejemplo el bitcoin funcione en parte
como si de acciones de bolsa se tratara
muchas personas compran bitcoins
esperando que tiempo después éstos suban
de precio para poder venderlos más caros
pero la alta volatilidad de la moneda
hace que esto sea muy riesgoso y además
el valor del bitcoin es altamente
afectado por múltiples valores externos
por ejemplo cuando china prohibió
cualquier actividad relacionada con su
uso la divisa se desplomó y cuando
empresarios como el magnate el on mars
que enviaron tweets apoyando la divisa
ésta se valorizó rápidamente cuáles son
los riesgos de las cripto monedas
hablemos primero en el plano
medioambiental para hacer minería de
bitcoins son necesarios servidores que
consumen muchísima energía habitaciones
enteras llena y tecnología para procesar
gran cantidad de datos para hacernos una
idea el minado de bitcoin mundial ya
consume en términos energéticos la misma
cantidad al año que argentina o países
bajos y esto supone una gran carga para
el planeta en el plano financiero la
volatilidad de estas monedas es también
un alto riesgo veamos sólo hace cinco
años la unidad de bitcoin costaba entre
600 y 900 dólares en octubre de 2021
alcanzó el máximo histórico de 66 mil
dólares pero dos meses después cayó a
menos de 50 mil quienes invierten en
bitcoins se arriesgan a ganar mucho oa
perder lo invertido otro factor de
riesgo es que al no estar controladas
nadie puede garantizar que las
inversiones estén a salvo bancos y
naciones debaten sobre incorporar o no
este sector emergente eeuu y la unión
europea sopesan regular estas divisas
otros como venezuela ya han creado su
propia cripto moneda y el salvador-
convirtió al bitcoin en moneda de curso
legal eclipsarán estas nuevas monedas
o su alta volatilidad las condenará al
fracaso sólo el tiempo lo dirá si le
sirvió el vídeo para entender que son
las cripto monedas los esperamos en otro
episodio de en 5 minutos aquí en france